what got me interested in insects well
my parents report that I was watching
ants when I was in diapers so I don't
really recall the first moments but I
was always there and supposedly I could
identify and I knew each individual ant
by her name so I would say that one's
Fred and Peter and Sally and Sue and
I've completely forgotten their
individual name I can't tell them apart
that well anymore but as a kid I
apparently knew every hand I was a
graduate student I came to Harvard to
send the other yo Wilson I didn't really
understand what Harvard was about and it
was like a lot of like tension and like
nervous people and super egos and so
forth and I wanted to get out of there
kind of super fast so I passed my oral
exams and get money to go to Asia and I
realized if I went over there and looked
for all these great stories the stories
that I wanted to find of all these ants
and creatures that people might think I
was sitting around smoking something
with a guru somewhere making stuff up
unless I could document somehow so I got
a book on how to photograph supermodels
and figured out that you needed a main
light a fill light and a hair light and
with these three lights you can get a
kind of a studio effect that's quite
beautiful so my aunt's have a nice hair
light so the hairs a sweetly backlit and
it gives them a like nice dimensionality
and also separates them from their
background and all kinds of things so
all you have to do is build this studio
into the front of your camera and carry
it around with you so I figured that out
Patience's of course important and you
have to be able to be in one place no
matter what it is in nature for a long
period of time and it's kind of ironic
because living in New York with all the
action activity and then you go to the
jungle and you're sometimes just sitting
there and utter quiet and not hearing a
human voice for days as you're waiting
for a flower to unfold or a snake to and
coil but when the moment happened to
have it in reality you have the truth
you have the truth of that moment and
people respect that I mean it's easily
some of these things are easily faked
and you see fakes all the time but the
true moment is a distinct thing and the
the movement even of an ant has a lot of
action and emotion to it if you catch
even an ant in its activity so that
difference is what makes National
Geographic great because they go after
these true moments how did I earn the
nickname Indiana Jones of entomology
well I I guess I get in a lot of battles
with small critters so one way or
another I tracked them down and I
actually have never really been
seriously bitten by anything
surprisingly uh most small creatures
respect me I like to thank and I know
how to approach them and handle them
without hurting them or getting hurt in
return so one way or another I just kind
of like it's it's a skill I have had
from my agent diapers watching ants this
is a capacity to to deal with insects
and and understand their world and get
down to their level and see them from
their own level where they tower over
you where they're impressive creatures
well was fairly worried about the Frog
as well because it's a it's a kind of a
long story I can tell bits of it but to
get to this frog you have to fly through
a tiny port city and then rent a boat
and go up a river and it's quite
elaborate and very few people have ever
done
so we arrived at this small town rented
a boat tried to go upriver and the water
was too low and a rental boat the
couldn't get up with this engine and we
were dropped off by the side of the
river by someone who is probably a drug
smuggler who was very angry that we
would didn't pay him the whole amount to
go the whole way and we worked our way
to an Indian village and get a dugout
canoe through some drinking of rice wine
and lots of negotiations over the next
day and we got this dugout canoe and we
had to drag it up river for two days
because the water was so low I had to
wear shorts and my skin I'm a pale pasty
guy and so I got sunburned so bad on my
legs that I had these huge blisters so
by the time I got to the frogs in this
remote village I could barely walk I had
to walk like Frankenstein on stiff legs
and so we got to the frogs and I was
worried because if the frogs touched me
they can potentially kill a person
so I basically covered myself with
plastic and I imbecile enveloped my legs
with plastic and my assistant who is a
part-time male stripper from Panama was
quite a character
he was a big meaty guy who could who was
very strong and liked to show off and so
because I couldn't move my legs he would
lower me to the ground and in front of
the Frog which would stop start hopping
towards me and I would take the pictures
and he would pick me up and move me away
so that the Frog couldn't touch me
so I managed the Frog pictures with this
technique well answer serious fighters
you know the Bible says go to the ant
thou sluggard consider her ways and be
wise and I don't know if the Solomon
King Solomon was referring to their
fighting skills he was probably
referring more to the fact that they
saved their food for periods of where
they were hungry and they were you know
careful about
the way they organize their lives in
other ways but ants first and foremost
for most people are fighters because
when they see us they are willing to be
kamikazes and ant is willing to die for
the cause all the time and there's even
an ant in Borneo that will blow up this
whole body will blow up so it's a
literal kamikaze suicide bomber ant when
it touches an enemy and Peru I
accidentally set on the most lethal
snake in the Americas which is the fare
to Lance and I would not recommend doing
this but I if you do do this you should
do it correctly you shouldn't sit
exactly as I did straight on a Ted and I
apparently compress its head down so
wasn't able to to bite me back but the
whole thing I should clarify was an
error and I don't think the snake
enjoyed it any more than I did how do I
protect myself when I'm in the field I
don't know I I never have troubles in
the field for some reason I seem to be
unnatural for what I do I'm rarely
bitten by anything I don't get sick I've
been with people who've gotten various
diseases and so forth but I never get
sick and so in a way for me it's more
natural than New York City I am much
more likely to get lost or make a wrong
term in new more kitty than I am in
Borneo